[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: All right.
Welcome, everybody.
Everyone ready for the quiz?
AUDIENCE: No.
JASON KU: Quiz next week.
Yes.
I hope you all are
here because you know
that there's a quiz next week.
OK.
So what is this quiz about?
It's about what
we've talked about so
far in this class of course.
What is this class about?
Someone remember from
my first lecture?
What is this class about?
What are we trying to
test you in this class?
AUDIENCE: Algorithims.
JASON KU: Algorithms.
Great.
Also data structures.
Right?
That's what the first
part of this is.
But really it's to get you to
solve computational problems.
That's the first thing.
Be able to argue to someone else
that you actually did solve it.
Right?
It's correct.
That you chose something that's
better than other things,
that it's efficient.
Right?
And that you can communicate
those things to other people.
Right?
Those are my big four that I try
to get you guys to internalize.
And so that's what
our quizzes are going
to try to evaluate you on.
OK.
And so aside from some
nitty gritty kind of stuff
that we do at the
beginning of the term
like talking about our
model of computation.
Right?
Our model-- and asymptotics.
Asym-- sym-- totics.
Is that right?
Recurrences right?
Aside from these
kind of basics, we
delve straight into algorithms.
Right?
These are kind of like
almost definitions.
We don't rely on these
things very much.
I mean, we rely on these
things all the time.
But it's kind of the
mathematics that we
use to talk about things.
Right?
How can we even say
how long this stuff
takes unless we can reason--
we can abstract a way
that this stuff is not
on a real computer.
This is kind of in our
minds, in a computer.
And we're reasoning
about these things based
on the number of
constant time operations
this magical
computer might have,
which is a pretty good
representation of any
of the computers you have
for certain assumptions.
Right?
We're not-- I mean, there's not
a lot of problem set questions
we had you talk about.
These things--
specifically-- usually they
were part of some other problem.
Right?
You had to describe the
running time of this thing.
And you might have had
to solve a recurrence.
And you might have
uses master theorem.
That kind of thing.
Right?
Or you use asymptotics
all the time.
Or you need to
remember in our model,
oh, it kind of matters
how big of an integer
I can store and do arithmetic
on in constant time.
Right?
So for that p-set
3 question you had
at the end of the
coding question,
you wanted to hash things.
And you need to argue
that those things fit
in a constant number
of words so that
could be done in constant time.
A lot of you guys
found canonicalizations
basically mapping to things
that were exponentially large.
So maybe multiplying a
product of primes or something
like that.
And that would not be
a good representation.
OK.
So these things come up, but
they're not the main focus
of the problems we solve.
What are the main focus of the--
how do we solve a computational
problem in this class?
I gave you two ways at
the beginning of the term.
Do you guys remember?
We can solve-- how to solve a
computational-- computational
problem.
One's the hard way.
One's the easy way.
AUDIENCE: Brute force.
JASON KU: Brute force.
OK.
So you're describing
to me a technique
for making your own algorithm.
Right?
I can just design my new
algorithm from scratch.
One way I could do
that is brute force it.
Right?
Look at all the possible
outputs and see which one works.
Right?
Or I could reduce to something
like divide and conquer
or something like that.
That's generally a
hard thing to do--
to make your own algorithm.
Right?
That's why we don't ask you
to do it a lot in this class.
It's an 046 kind of thing.
Right?
So the first thing you could do
is write design a new algorithm
from scratch.
Usually it's not from scratch.
Right?
Usually you're reducing to
some kind of algorithmic design
paradigm that you've
maybe heard of.
You'll talk a lot more about it
in 046 and at the end of this
term when we talk about
dynamic programming.
But generally, that's
a hard thing to do.
Right?
You're trying to think
of a recursive algorithm.
Right?
You're trying to prove
that it's correct--
all these nitty gritty--
we have actually,
throughout the
class in lectures,
have been showing
you the algorithms.
But we're not really expecting
you to make those algorithms.
What are we expecting you
to do most of the time.
Yeah?
To reduce it to a problem that
we showed you how to solve.
Right?
I'm going to say
thing here, but really
what I mean is an algorithm
that we've taught you to--
basically here-- reduced
to a known thing--
to known thing.
Usually that means there's
a problem or an interface
that we've given you.
And in general, we've shown
you multiple different ways
to solve that
problem or interface.
Right?
So we've shown you many
ways on how to sort things.
And we've shown you many
ways on how to implement
sequence and set interfaces.
Remember?
And a lot of times
the types of problems
that we're asking you to do
is to just use as a black box
some of the things that we did.
But you need, as a programmer,
as a computer scientist,
you need to tell me when
I should use what went.
Right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you clarify what
you mean by use as a black box?
JASON KU: Use as a black box.
Exactly.
Right.
So this is a phrase that
I use and a lot of people
in computer science use.
It's basically you import
a library into your code.
Right?
What do I have?
I have an API.
I have a way to
interact with that code.
I don't actually
know what's going
on inside of that library.
I'm using it as a black box.
It's opaque to me.
I cannot look inside--
I can actually probably could
look inside what their code is,
but I'm not going to.
The thing that makes
it useful to me
is that has this
useful API that I
trust it to do the
things that you told me
that it was going to do.
Right?
And so there's kind of--
I'm going to jump around a
little bit here actually,
because that's a great question.
So here I think of there's three
different types of problems
that we talk about, that
we give you in this class.
You might have seen
this on the problem set.
Right?
I like to categorize them into
three different categories
here.
One is you have to understand
the internals of a data
structure, an
algorithm that we know.
You have to be able to look
inside and, I don't know,
given a node in a balanced
binary search tree--
an AVL tree--
how can I do a rotation?
Right?
Or how do I do an insert?
Or something about the
structure of this thing--
a binary heap--
where are the top k
things in a max binary heap,
which is on your problem set.
Those things require me to very
much not black box these data
structures.
It's a white box.
Right?
I need to know what's inside of
that to answer that question.
Right?
I need to know about the
internals of that data
structure.
Right?
And there are other types of
problems where it's like, oh,
I don't need to know what
the internals of this data
structure is.
I can just operate with
knowledge of the API
and try to hook it in to
the problem that I need.
And that's what I call a
reduction type problem.
This is how does the core
material we presented
to you in lecture work?
This is how do I apply
that core material?
And harder than
both of those things
is what I might call a
modification type of--
these aren't really good names.
I came up with
these this morning.
But it's trying
to get at the idea
here that it's possible that you
need to know what the API is,
and you need to know what's
going on inside to be
able to answer the problem.
Things like adapting a
divide and conquer algorithm.
Or making-- instead of
using a dynamic array that
has extra space on
one end, maybe I
have to put extra space in the
middle or something like that.
Right?
I'm adapting something that
was from the core material.
It's pretty close.
But I have to modify
it in some way.
Augmentation right?
I have to take the vanilla
said AVL tree that I might
have given you and put some
other property on the nodes
and you need to tell me
how to maintain that.
How can I compute that subtree
property from its children?
Does that make sense?
So this is the
harder of the things.
Right?
If you can identify
which one of these--
a problem that you
look at on an exam--
[INAUDIBLE] under--
maybe that can help you
conceptualize what should I use.
For a reduction type problem--
I'm going to talk about
this in a second--
but a lot of times it's
useful to reduce it
to a problem or an interface
rather than an algorithm
or a data structure.
What does that mean?
If I can solve the problem by
saying reducing to sorting,
I can argue to you that
that algorithm is correct.
I just use sorting
as a black box.
Now it might not be efficient.
My choice of sorting
algorithm that I chose matters
for efficiency.
But for correctness,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
For a data structures
problem I might
reduce to using two set
data structures and sequence
data structure or
something like that.
But it will be correct if I
reduce it to those things.
I can define the operations
in terms of those interfaces.
I don't have to make
that choice until I
talk about running time.
Right?
Until I talk about efficiency.
And the name of the game
on the quiz to get points--
we can't give you points
for an incorrect algorithm
or something that's
pretty close to correct.
Right?
And we can't give
you full points
unless the correct algorithm
you give us is efficient
and that you've argued things
like correctness and running
time and things like that.
Your algorithm could be
correct and efficient,
but you analyzed the
running time incorrectly
so we mark you
points off for there.
Or most of the time what
you do is you present us
with an inefficient algorithm.
And then you analyze
the running time
as if it's the target running
time that we gave you.
Right?
That's bad on two fronts.
OK.
So try not to fall
into these traps.
OK.
So some general test
taking strategies when
you're looking at your quiz.
I really strongly urge you to
read through the entire exam
before you start because
some of the problems
will be easier for
you than others.
And if you're trying
to maximize points
on here as all of you, I'm
sure, are trying to do,
it's useful to make that initial
pass through the problems
to see which ones
are easiest for you.
And then you can tackle
them in the order
in which you have confidence.
Now in actuality, the average
on say quiz one of this class
tends to be around, I don't
know, between 60 and 80.
I don't think it's ever been 80.
But it's not 100.
So doing 50% of the
problems well is probably
going to be better for you
in terms of time management
and those kinds of things
than doing all of the--
attempting all of
the problems and not
doing great on any of
them in terms of point--
you have to, in
computer science,
you have to be pretty close to
a correct answer to get points.
Right?
It basically needs to be almost
correct or you don't get--
if you've seen how
your problem sets are
being graded-- sometimes
our problem set
graders make mistakes.
Sometimes they give you points
for an incorrect solution.
Right?
It's really on you to take
a look at your problem sets
that you gave us and our
solutions that we gave you.
We spent a lot of time writing
good solutions for you guys.
You need to make sure
that the material.
Don't come up to us
at the end of an exam
and say, oh, I said the same
thing on my problem set.
It was marked correct and
you guys marked it wrong.
Well, yeah.
The staff knows
a little bit more
about algorithms than your
graders on your problem sets.
And we grade your exams.
So unfortunately,
that's not an excuse.
It's on you to
know the material.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So are
most of the problems
on the exams multiple
part things where
we need to have a
good understanding
and do the first
few parts in order
to get even partial
credit on the other parts?
Or is it like [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Yeah.
So the question
is, are questions
built on top of each other so
that you're kind of at a wall
if you missed the first part?
We try not to design
exams that way.
OK.
You can actually take a
look at the practice exam
that's already been posted.
Our problems tend to
be self-contained.
And if they are multiple
parts, the parts
are usually independent.
Usually you don't need to
have done A correctly in order
to do B correctly.
All right?
And that's how our problem
sets try to be written as well.
For your last coding
question and 4
you had this problem
where you had
to design this data structure.
But C said use
that as a black box
essentially and
solve the problem.
Right?
So you actually
don't need to show--
we've given you this interface.
You can just use
that interface to be
able to answer C, the
algorithms question,
without even solving the data
structures question correctly.
Does that make sense?
And actually, the
algorithms question
was the easier one there, I
think, from what I remember.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we have to
write code on the exam?
JASON KU: Do you have to
I've never given an exam where
you've had to write code.
I have written exams where
you have to read code.
OK?
So pseudocode or Python--
since Python's a
prerequisite for this class,
it's completely fair
game that we give you
small snippets of
Python code and you
have to be able to
understand what's going on.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You
listed amortization
under the modification
[INAUDIBLE]..
Does that mean we're using
an amortized [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: Yeah.
What I mean here--
amortization certainly
appears in here or here--
these kinds of things.
Oftentimes if I'm
using a dynamic array,
if I'm using a binary heap,
if I'm using a hash table,
amortization will appear
here in our running times
for those dynamic operations.
What I mean here
in amortization--
I mean if I'm asking you
to generalize something
that we've done like with
dynamic arrays where instead
of adding additional
space at the end,
I'm putting additional
space in the middle
or at the beginning or
something like that.
And you're having to do some
kind of amortized analysis.
Now, often it's
unnecessary to do this in--
when we talked about
a problem where
we did do our own
amoritized analysis
and making a double ended deck--
I mean a double ended queue--
you could actually
solve it by reducing
to using two dynamic arrays.
Right?
So there's a lot of
ways in which you
could reduce to using things.
But you might have to do
some additional bookkeeping
at the end.
But what this is saying
is that these are more--
you're not using
things as a black box.
You're changing something about
the boxes that we gave you.
Right?
Does that make sense.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you tell us to
write an algorithm that does
something like O(log n)
time, and we can think only
of an algorithm that does
something inefficiently like
O(n) at end time.
JASON KU: OK.
AUDIENCE: Then is there
any point writing that?
JASON KU: Sure.
So let's actually
move on for a second.
I actually-- I'm going to
answer your question very soon.
OK.
But I'm going to get
to it in a second.
OK?
If I don't answer that question
in five minutes, please let me
know.
OK?
So the first thing,
when I'm approaching
a problem on the
exam, I might try
to ask some questions
about the problem.
OK.
It's going to help me
decide what to use.
Right?
Different than
your problems sets.
Your problem sets--
basically, what
do you use is what did we talk
about in lecture that week.
On a quiz you have
eight lectures
that you've talked about.
And so this is going
to be a harder thing
for you to do because you don't
know which of the eight lecture
material is going to
apply to this problem.
And it could be a
combination of them actually.
And so I'm trying to give
you ways of answering
that question faster.
OK?
So is this a
mechanical reduction
or a modification type problem?
That's just going to help
me determine the difficulty
level of what this is.
You might not be
able to answer it.
But it can give you a sense
for what kind of problem it is.
Is this a problem about data
structures sorting both?
Right?
If it's about data
structures, do I
need to support
sequence type operations
or do I need to store an
extrinsic order on something?
Or is it a thing where I care
about what the objects are?
I'm trying to look things
up by what they are.
Or maybe both?
Or maybe some combination?
If I have a bunch of
different types of keys
that I might want
a query on, I might
have to use at least two
set type of data structures.
Right?
You could get very
complicated with these things.
But putting it in
terms of well, I'm
going to need to do this kind
of operation on these names.
Then I can think, oh, I need
a set data structure there.
I'll think about how to
implement that later.
Should I use a hash table?
Should I use a sorted array?
Should I use a AVL tree?
But thinking about it first
at the abstract level of I
need a set data structure here
can help you compartmentalize
correctness versus efficiency.
Does that make sense?
OK.
If you're stuck, this
is your question.
If you're stuck, write
down a correct algorithm
that's inefficient.
We can give you points for
a correct algorithm that's
inefficient.
At least it's a
correct algorithm.
That's better than other things.
Right?
Now, if it's
exponential time, you
might be limited to 10%
or 20% of the points.
But if it's a log factor--
worse, or linear factor-- worse.
Maybe that's OK.
On a data structures problem,
if any operation takes order n
time, that's probably not going
to give you a lot of points
because the whole point
of the data structure
is to make those
operations fast.
But if it solves the problem,
you'll get some points.
You won't get 0 points.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Will we
get any questions
that are like how fast
can you make this?
Make this as fast as possible.
JASON KU: Yeah.
So a lot of times we'll say,
give us an efficient algorithm.
OK.
It's like, whoa, I don't know
if it's efficient or not.
Well, that just means that
faster running times are
going to give you more points.
OK?
So in questions like
that, it's mostly
trying to play this game of--
usually, we'll put an efficient
one in not in terms of a data
structure because usually,
the data structures problem--
it's important in
your implementation
that these data structure
operations be fast.
And we want to tell
you how fast is.
Right?
So data structures questions
in general, there's
usually a trade-off
between running times
of these different operations.
And it's really important how
they relate to each other.
And so for data
structures problem,
it's kind of about getting
those running times.
OK?
With an algorithms problem
where we ask you to do one thing
and we try to do it
as fast as possible,
try to get linear time.
Right?
Most of the time you can't
get better than linear time
if you have to read the
entire input at some point
if I want to find the
things in my data.
And if you can't think of
a linear time algorithm,
think of an n squared thing
or think of n log n thing.
Right?
Maybe that's a little hard for
you guys to think of right now.
But that's why I'm saying start
with any correct algorithm
and then maybe you can optimize.
Maybe you can use a
better data structure
to make it more efficient.
Does that make sense?
Any other questions?
OK.
Moving right along.
Here's some downsides.
OK.
If you find yourself doing one
of these things three things,
take a step back.
You're probably doing
something wrong.
OK?
So question yourself if you're
trying to compute decimals,
rationals, or real numbers.
I can't store
those things on a--
I mean, I can store decimals
to finite precision.
But if you're doing
finite precision,
you might as well multiply your
numbers by that fixed precision
and deal with the integers.
Right?
We only have taught
you how to deal
with the integers in this class.
Right?
We haven't even shown you
how to efficiently compute
on rationals and real numbers.
We have told you if you have
a denominator and a numerator
of a fraction, I can
take two fractions
and compare them
right in constant time
by doing cross multiplication.
But if I'm trying to actually
do this division to arbitrary
precision, that's not
happy because I can't even
represent that on my
computer in a finite number
of decimal points for
some of these things.
If you're trying to use
Radix sort for every answer,
it's probably wrong.
One of the things that we
try to do on our quizzes--
we're not just giving you a
bunch of problems randomly.
We probably are
making problems that
cover the material in some way.
We do want to test you
on all of the things.
And so if you find that
you're using the same thing
four or five times
on the exam, that
might be a sign that you're
using it too many times.
It's not always the case.
Right?
Sometimes hashing
is super useful,
so you want to use
it all the time.
But in particular,
everyone tries
to use Radix sort when
it's inappropriate.
And they love because
it gets linear time.
Right?
But if you write merge sort for
something where Radix sort will
apply, you'll get some points
because it's correct but not
efficient.
And it's inefficient
by a log factor.
Right?
If you're trying to use
Radix sort in a situation
where comparisons are the
answer and you don't have
a bound on the integers,
if I don't have
a bound on the size
of the integers,
then this may be taking
a huge amount of time.
So I might not
even think of that
as being correct because it
could be exponential time.
I mean, I don't know.
I don't know how
big my word size is.
It could be arbitrarily bad.
OK.
And then if you're
trying to augment
a binary tree with something
that's not a subtree property--
something that can't be
computed from the augmentations
of its two children--
you're doing something bad.
Every exam we have
30% of students
say augment by my index in the
entire tree or augment by--
here's one that's fun--
augment by the size
of my left subtree--
the number of nodes
in my left subtree.
How can I--
I'm not sure how I can maintain
that with rotations and things
like that.
Let's see.
In order for me to keep
track of the augmentation
of my left tree from the
augmentation of my left tree,
I have to do a logarithmic
walk all the way down the thing
to figure out how many
things were there.
So that's not a maintainable
thing in constant time.
If I want to augment
something of my left subtree,
just augment the thing
itself and just look
at your left subtree and
look at its augmentation.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you had say,
augmented it with a subtree
and then augmented it again with
[INAUDIBLE] subtree and then
use that--
JASON KU: You could do that.
AUDIENCE: --does
that still count as--
JASON KU: You could do that.
Yeah.
So you could do that
in constant time
by augmenting by subtree size.
Right?
AUDIENCE: And then have another
augmentation in [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: You could have another
augmentation because then you
could just look at-- but then
just look at your left subtree
please.
Yeah.
No reason to store it again.
Right?
You just do one constant time--
look to your left.
OK.
Don't do that.
So that is-- cool.
I'm not that far behind.
Those are my tips on
solving questions.
Oh, there's one more page.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when
defining an augmentation,
[INAUDIBLE] do the formula and
argue that it's [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: Exactly.
Right.
So the idea is if you give an
augmentation that's not a--
we're going to talk
about our standard things
you can reduce to in a second.
If you're saying, I'm
going to take a set AVL
tree or a sequence AVL tree--
and for example, at
the end of lecture,
we were talking about how
a sequence AVL tree could
be modified to
support priority queue
operations in the same
running times as binary heaps.
Right?
And that was saying we
store our subtree maxes--
the max thing in my subtree.
Right?
And so that's a
different augmentation
than what's already augmented
on the sequence AVL tree.
What are the augmentations
on a sequence AVL tree?
AUDIENCE: Size.
JASON KU: Size.
AUDIENCE: Count.
JASON KU: So counts is the
same thing as how many nodes
are in my subtree.
And?
AUDIENCE: Height.
JASON KU: Height.
Right because it's an AVL tree.
Right?
So if I'm augmenting
by max in my subtree,
that's not part of my
standard interface.
So you need to tell me that.
Even though we've
done it before,
it should be very easy for you.
Just say, I'm
augmenting by my max.
Max can be computed
as the max between me
and my left and right
subtree if they exist.
Done.
Right?
But just do that.
You have to tell me--
and it takes
constant time, so it
can be maintained at constant
time when I'm doing my stuff.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So the last thing,
I guess especially
on the data
structures problems, I
would suggest that you
approach these things
by solving these problems just
in terms of the interfaces
first.
Because then at least you
get something that's correct.
And then choose the
algorithms or data structures
that you use to implement
those interfaces afterwards.
One gets you to a
correct algorithm.
The other is for efficiency.
Decoupling these might help
you in solving the problem.
If it doesn't help you, don't.
If you're like, whenever I
see a set data structure,
I'm going to probably use a hash
table, that's probably fine.
But if we're looking for
worst case time bounds,
that's probably not fun.
So you just--
I'm suggesting that you separate
these things so that you
concentrate on solving
the problem first
and then optimize it later.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just a question
in regards to worst case
time bounds.
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So for a hash table.
AUDIENCE: Given that's
a code one expected.
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: That also implies
that's O of n worst case.
So could you --technically
JASON KU: It doesn't imply that.
It is that.
So, I mean, you could have
a data structure whose
expected time bound is constant,
but it's a worst case bound
is n log n.
It just happens to be the
fact that for a hash table,
those worst case
operations are linear.
But if I --had we had a
question up here beforehand,
if I had a running time
bound that I did something
to a hash table in constant
expected time, I did a look up,
and then I queried an a AVL tree
for the predecessor of a node
or something like
that, and I did
that in O of log n time,
what's the worst case running
time of that?
AUDIENCE: O of n.
JASON KU: O of n.
What's the expected
running time of this thing?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
JASON KU: Log n.
Expected log n.
Because it's possible
that in the worst case
it could be higher.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
--so OK.
The second bullet is just
setting up a data structures
problem.
There's a lot of moving parts.
We're going to do two
data structures problem
at the end of this session.
Describe all of the data
structures you're using,
including what they store.
If you're storing a
set data structure,
you better tell me what
the things you're stored
are keyed on.
Usually the things
that we're storing
contain a bunch of
information, and if you just
say I'm storing all of
the toppings of my pizza
in the set data structure,
and that's all you tell me,
I have no idea what
you're talking about
because I don't know what
the semantics of your data
structure are.
What is it keyed on?
I have to say,
oh, it's keyed on,
I don't know the y's
or something like that.
OK.
And there are invariants.
How we're setting up these
data structures problem,
usually how I solve these when
I'm writing the solutions,
I set up a state of what
this data structure could
be at some instance.
I'm going to say,
this data structure
stores all of the
things less than --k
with key less than
k, blah, blah, blah.
And this one stores
the extrinsic order
of the items based
on blah, blah, blah.
OK.
So actually, me stating
what they store in that way
is actually imposing some kind
of invariant on these data
structures that I'm
wanting to maintain.
But what I need to do to prove
that this thing is correct
is that based on the assumption
that those invariants held
before my operation.
Then I can prove that
an operation is correct
if all of those invariants
are maintained before, then
after the operation.
That's kind of how I'm proving
that this thing is correct.
And then when I'm querying,
I'm doing some kind of lookup
on this data structure, I
can rely on those invariants.
I know that those
things are good,
those things have
been maintained,
and so I can rely on
those to look up what's
the largest k of this thing.
Does that make sense?
If this is very
abstract, we're going
to get a little bit more
concrete in just a second.
And then implement
every operation.
You have no idea
how many solutions
we read on the quizzes,
which we give you
three operations to implement
and you don't even mention one.
And it's usually
the easiest one.
It's like inserted into
your data structure.
It's like, come
on, just say that.
We can't give you points unless
you mention that operation.
Does that make sense?
And then it's going
to help --us happy
graders give you more points.
Not really, but if
your solution is
well-organized and well-labeled
and things like that,
then we're going to be able to
comprehend your solution better
and we'll be able to
give you more points.
Remember, part of this class
is about communication.
If your thing is correct but we
can't tell what you're saying,
then it's not correct.
OK.
All right.
So now we get --to
any questions on that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a
question on invariants.
So one of the data
structures that we've
discussed in the
class previously
to state like what
the invariants are,
like the set AVL tree rule.
JASON KU: Right.
So if it's the
standard things, we
were going to talk about what
the standard things are now.
Then you don't need to
re-argue or --restate
I mean, you can
basically say like,
because the set and sequence
interfaces are defined
that way, these
things are correct,
like --almost you
can --basically
you're trying to convince
us that why it's correct.
If you're correctly using
a set or sequence data
structure in these data
structures-type problems, then
unless you're using it
in a way that is unusual,
usually you can just
rely on the properties
of the set and sequence data
structures that we gave you.
I do want you to mention that
you thought about correctness.
Like this data structure
is correct because.
Just write a sentence
saying that and arguing
that you're
basically maintaining
the invariance of your
data structure kind
of at the upper level.
What kinds of things is
this data structure storing?
What things about the
global data structure
are we relying on to
make query operations?
As long as you are convincing
that after a dynamic operation
when modifying the data
structure that those invariant
stay the --same that are
still satisfied, then
that's really all
you need to say.
These invariants are
satisfied because
of the definitions of a set
and sequence data structure.
A lot of times it doesn't
require a lot of thought
for --the we're not
--asking the reason
why we do reduction
problems is so you
don't have to do a lot of
work to prove to us that it's
correct.
We have these really
nice black boxes.
They are correct.
We proved them to you
that they're correct,
and so you don't have
to redo that work.
So now we're going to go
through the core material I like
to think about in this class.
The first part of
this class, aside
from these mathematical
tools that we developed
at the beginning
of the course, it's
mostly about solving problems
involving data structures.
And we motivated this
problem of sorting
by saying that a sorted array
is a data structure that's
actually pretty useful.
But how do we sort those things?
Well, we showed you a
bunch of ways to do that.
And this is that nice table.
Lots of stuff.
Why do we show you so
many sorting algorithms?
Why don't we just give
you one algorithm?
Hmm?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: --run times.
JASON KU: Different run times.
AUDIENCE: Better for --different
JASON KU: Better for
different scenarios.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
They each have their
own individual points,
then they do better.
JASON KU: Yeah.
You'll notice in
this table, there's
not blue all the way across
for any of these things.
So some of them are better
for different scenarios.
And actually, these comments
list some special cases where
these things might be better.
In actuality, this
ultra-blue thing
is saying like this
could be linear time.
That's better.
But in some cases this is worse
than all the other things.
So be a little wary of
this blue color here.
Generally we're trying to get
you further down in this chart
if you can.
And in general, like for
example, merge sort, AVL sort,
these are really the same in
terms of asymptotic complexity
and the way in which you
interact with these sorting
rooms.
But there are
special cases where
you might use insertion sort
or selection --sort actually,
I'm not sure about
insertion sort.
You had in your
recitation two days ago--
I think you guys
showed how to do
if you had a k-proximate array
where things are not more
than k away from each other.
Insertion sort actually
runs in n times k,
and so if k is small,
then that's really good,
that's kind of like linear.
But you can actually
do even better
with a binary heap, which you
saw in recitation, hopefully,
where you can get that down to
n log k by --keeping maintaining
a heap as you go across and
finding the max that way.
So insertion sort
maybe is not so great.
But selection sort,
the name of the game
there is that if
my reads are cheap
but my writes are
expensive, selection sort
it actually does pretty
well, because I only have--
sorry.
Reads are cheap and my
writes are expensive.
Selection sort does a
linear number of swaps.
It's looking down, finding
the max, swapping it in,
and keep it going.
And so in such cases,
that's actually
better than any of these other
algorithms that we've got.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Those heap --sorts
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --time, worst
case are expected.
JASON KU: This is worst case.
So it's a little hard to--
there was a lot of moving
parts to get to this bound
in Tuesday's lecture.
Basically what we
did, we showed you
how to think of an
array as a heap--
as a binary tree.
Complete binary tree.
It's not an AVL--
I mean, it is an AVL
tree, but AVL trees
are weaker than a complete tree.
Height balance is a weaker
property than a complete.
The reason why we use
complete is because it's
unique for a number of nodes.
That way, when I give you one
array with a fixed length,
I know exactly what tree
you're talking about,
because there's a
one-to-one mapping there.
If there was some ambiguity on
what tree I was talking about,
I --wouldn't heaps
just wouldn't work.
So what heap sort does is
it has this correspondence
between arrays and binary trees.
And then what it
does is it provides
these operations that kind of
only do operations at the end.
And then the
in-place optimization
is that, well, instead of
actually popping it or pushing
it onto the back
of an array, I'm
just going to think of a
subset of my array as a heap
and then always kind of
pooping the max out to the end.
Just leaving it behind
and thinking of my heap
as a smaller subset.
And that's how we --got
it didn't actually
de-use any amortization.
For the time bound, time
bounds you could actually
do this with the amortized
basically dynamic array
version of this.
The time bound
doesn't rely on that.
The in-place relies on keys
staying all within one array.
Does that make sense?
You're doing a bunch of
amortized operations,
so that this actually does
achieve worst case n log n.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It seems that
the things we learned--
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --not like--
AUDIENCE: They
tend to be better.
So assume that most algorithms
than we want them to be--
JASON KU: Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: --faster.
It seems like people will
not use as often, especially
in these [INAUDIBLE]
insertion and selection.
JASON KU: Right, yeah.
So there are these special
cases where they're good,
but, I mean, generally
these are better
general data structures
for most situations
that you come across.
I mean, there are cases where
those other things are good,
so you don't want to
completely ignore them,
but generally, yeah, you're
trying to be lower bound
in this chart.
AUDIENCE: What I mean is that
if I don't have any --bound like
I'm using them all except
for selection sort--
JASON KU: So there's
too many things on here
for us to test all
of them on an exam.
So don't be afraid if not
everything is covered.
Worry when things are
covered 18 times on the exam,
that's not good.
OK.
So for radix sort,
there are situations
where you get linear time.
It's when you're
polynomial-bounded.
Are there times
when I want to use
radix sort when I'm
not polynomial-bounded
in my integers?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you're
not polynomial-bounded,
then that could take
a really long time.
JASON KU: Sure, yeah.
But like where's --the this
will be worse than n log n when?
It's definitely
better than n log n
when u is polynomially bounded.
Because it's linear.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
n to the n.
JASON KU: n to the n.
OK.
So if I put n to
the n in here, I
get an n factor
that comes out here.
That gives me a
quadratic running time,
which is not great.
But when will this be
better then n log n?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: n to the c,
because it's less n to the c.
JASON KU: n to the c--
so that'll definitely
give us linear time.
That's what this is saying.
But we can actually
do better than n log n
if this u is n to the c
times log n for some c.
If --it's like if it's
n to the c log log n,
that's smaller than log n.
So that's a better algorithm.
That's a faster algorithm.
Do you guys see why we
wrote these things this way?
It's so that we give
you a more --precise
this is more important for you
understand what u means here
than that this thing
sometimes runs in linear time.
We want to know when
it runs in linear time.
Does that makes sense?
Or when it runs faster
than merge sort.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So that's sorting.
We have sequence-type
data structures.
We have linked lists,
we have dynamic arrays,
we have sequence AVLs.
Sequence AVLs are great.
I don't know why
no one teaches it.
They're great.
They don't teach it probably
because they're actually not
that useful.
You don't actually use the
insert in the middle a lot
in coding.
So it's-- you can usually
get around with like shifting
something to the end and doing
dynamic operations there,
and that's a lot of the games
that you try to play so you
don't have to make your
own data structures,
and you can just use the
Python list that's in your--
like native to your thing.
But it has a
theoretical interest
because it gets these
kind of balanced bounds
if you need to insert in
the middle of this sequence.
Now some of you look at me
and had a question before that
was like, but Jason,
how does linked list
operations on the
end of a linked list,
why does that take linear time?
It's because in lecture,
we presented you with what?
A singly-linked list.
It just had pointers
to the next thing.
And if I only have pointers to
the next thing and a pointer
to the head, for
me to find the end,
I need to walk all
the way down the list.
Now let's say I keep my pointer
to the tail, then finding that
and n1 is fine, but removing
it still takes linear time,
because I don't know
what came before me.
And so that's why in
p-set whatever, 1, 2,
I don't remember, you
stored a pointer back
to your previous one that
gave you doubly-linked lists.
Yay, right?
So actually, expanding
this table out,
you can reference a
doubly-linked list here and get
this one as constant time.
Does that make sense?
And this one's
still linear time.
OK.
But this one's
still linear time.
We actually also
showed you how to do
this in constant amortized.
Do you guys remember that?
That was in problem
session 2 or 1?
I don't remember.
It was whatever we talking
about amortized stuff.
We --got we got
actually both of these
to one amortized using the
concepts of the dynamic array.
And then we actually
did it one more time
where we got a good
doubly-ended thing.
What was that?
Does anyone remember?
We went to problem session 3.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I'm probably wrong, this is--
JASON KU: OK.
AUDIENCE: --problem session 3.
But like q dq type stuff?
JASON KU: So q dq,
those are talking
about doubly-ended things.
Those are implemented in a
certain way, which is actually
one of these things.
It's actually, I think,
this one in Python.
But there's --a we used a
different data structure
to get something that
had really good at.
It had really good
pop and append
and first and last
dynamic operations.
Do you --guys anyone
remember from session 3?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
dynamic array [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: That's what this was.
OK.
We got one that had
expected bounds.
Does that help?
What?
I heard someone say it.
Hash table.
Yeah.
So basically what you
did, instead --of this
is a sequence thing.
These things don't have keys.
But I could identify
with each item
as I stick it in, a key
representing its index.
And I could use a
hash table that way.
Now there was some difficulty
if I removed the first thing.
Because actually, how
--those are all of my indices
have now changed.
But if I just store what the
smallest index in my thing is,
then I'm golden,
because I can compute
what that index should be I
change things at the front.
OK.
So there's actually
three different ways
we showed you of getting
constant time at the front
and the back of this thing.
So actually, you can think
of that as standard material
that you can reduce to.
That's the one
exception of the things
that I'm not showing
on this chart,
but is a bonus if you're
watching this problem session.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So isn't a hash table
a set data structure, though?
JASON KU: It is.
But we used it to implement
a sequenced data structure.
So I will refer you to
that problem session
if you want to
learn more about it.
So, any questions on
sequenced data structures?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I--
JASON KU: Yeah, uh huh.
AUDIENCE: Should
we be-- or-- yeah.
Should we be able to look prove
the tables that we're given?
JASON KU: So I would hope--
hope-- that if I gave you
a blank table, that you
would be able to fill it out.
That's how well I
want you to know how
these things are implemented.
We're not going to
have that on the exam.
That's a boring
kind of question.
AUDIENCE: But it is
important to know?
JASON KU: Yeah.
I would-- it's good
for you to think,
like, oh, if I'm going
to use an AVL tree,
operations are generally
going to be log n.
That's a really useful
thing-- or, if I'm
going to use a hash table,
dictionary-type operations,
finding, inserting, and
deleting, those are fast.
Doing order-type operations
on hash tables is bad,
that's hard to do because
I have to basically look
through all my things.
Knowing that dynamic operations
on a sorted array is bad.
Or knowing that-- you have to
think about here what we mean
when we say linked list and
dynamic array in this table,
because--
AUDIENCE: Singly-linked.
JASON KU: Yeah, exactly.
We are implying
singly-linked here
because that's what we
presented to you in lecture.
And so those are
the standard things
that we want you to reduce to.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: --three modified
standard things are
the doubly-linked lists,
the doubly-ended--
JASON KU: Yeah.
Basically you can
assume that you have--
it's this one that you
probably want to use,
because you get
constant indexing.
And then pretty
good on both ends.
But if you need
a double-ended Q,
you can also reduce it to having
two dynamic arrays back-to-back
when going this way,
when going this way.
And so there's lots of--
we're not going to give that
to you as a standard method
because there's literally like
four methods we showed you
how to do.
So you choose one.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the interest
of saving time on the exam,
if we want to say, like, we do
this thing with the sequence
AVL and it takes log n time.
Do we have to say the
sentence like, because this
is sequence AVL, it takes
a longer time because this?
Or can we just like say like,
for the table that we know?
JASON KU: Yeah, no.
If you told me that you're
storing things in a sequence
AVL and you just say--
you basically say what
you do to it, and you say,
which takes blah,
blah, blah time,
you don't need to say
because it's a sequence AVL,
because you already told
us it's a sequence AVL.
I believe that you
probably wrote the chart
on your cheat sheet
and you looked it up.
All right.
Any other questions on this?
No.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just make sure,
the doubly-linked lists
will make the insert
on [INAUDIBLE]..
Is that the only change?
JASON KU: Yes.
That doubly-linked list
gives this guy constant time.
And actually, there are
two operations here,
insert, delete, and--
I guess there's a
find here as well.
If I just store
the tail pointer,
that gets defined
to constant time.
but it doesn't get the
dynamic ones to constant time.
I need to store the previous
pointers as well at each node.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Lastly-- or I guess second to
lastly, set data structures.
There are a little
bit more of these.
Not so many more.
But yeah.
We had a sorted array, gets
good find, but is not dynamic.
We set AVL tree which
does pretty good
find and is dynamic.
Again, you get this n
log n overhead to build,
because essentially what you're
doing with both of those data
structures is to sort.
But if I'm looking
on a theory question,
like I'm not asking
you something
specifically about a
sorted array, if you
have a choice between this
data structure and this data
structure, which
one do you choose?
Well, I don't quite
know, because it's
almost like this one's better at
everything except for this one.
But can anyone tell me how to
make this one constant time
as well?
Augmentation.
I could just store in my
subtrees the max or min.
And I can make this one
strictly better than this one.
So in theory
problem, you probably
just want to use this one.
Here, hash tables,
direct access arrays,
even better for
these operations.
That's great.
But they suck at these.
So if you need these,
don't use these.
And in actual coding,
especially if you're
coding in a language that's not
Python, something that doesn't
automatically give
you a hash table,
if you're in C in a
microcontroller lab at MIT
here, you're taking
6115 or whatever,
and you're doing assembly,
usually what you're doing
is a direct access stuff.
Because that's
giving you the jumps
that you need in
machine language
to actually go and access
this in constant time.
That's generally if you
have control over the keys
that you're putting--
that you are putting
in your data structure,
you don't want this
overhead of running
your keys through
a hash function
to look these things up.
You just store the
things in an array.
You use the hash
table when you don't
have control over
the keys or your keys
are like strings or something.
So that's when you
use the hash table.
Now for our purposes,
usually a hash table
is just as good unless
we're asking you
for worst case bounds.
And we're going to do this
when we talk about the data
structures problem.
If we give you a situation where
we don't care if you achieve
worst case are
expected or amortized
or any of these
things, we'll just
say, make sure you state
which one you achieve.
And as long as you analyzed
it correctly with respect
to your data structures,
then you're fine.
But if we say you better
do worst case here,
I'm going to slap you around.
Then please get those bounds.
Don't use the hash
table in that case.
That makes sense?
OK.
Lastly, we've got priority
queues which we talked about.
I'm not going to go
through this one very much.
It's basically just
adding this to the thing.
But in actuality, you can
get all of these bounds
with a set AVL--
I mean a sequence AVL tree
with max or min augmentation,
which isn't on this list because
we didn't really talk about it,
but hopefully you can--
if you need these bounds
without the amortization,
then you could achieve them.
All right.
So that's basically
everything that we've
talked about in the class.
We're going to spend the rest
of the time working a couple
of data structures problem.
I'm not-- there's a number of
different types of questions
you'll actually
see on the quiz--
the practice quiz that we
gave you from last term.
There are some what I call
mechanical-type questions up
at the front.
Then usually some
reduction-type problems
where you're reducing to
using some sorting algorithms
or some data structures.
And then usually
the latter ones are
ones where you have to do some
kind of something additional,
like some augmentation or
some divide and conquer
or something like that.
OK.
So we're going to
go ahead and spend
the rest of the time working
a couple of these problems.
These were from spring
of 2019 on the exam.
And actually, one of the
TAs who's TAing for us
now was also TAing
for us in spring 2019.
Was grading problem
number 2 here,
the rainy research
problem, and just hated me,
because no one did it right.
All right.
So, let's try to
solve these problems.
So problem 1 is
about restaurant--
restaurant, yes, OK.
All right.
So basically, what's happening?
A popular restaurant,
Criminal Seafood.
What's the reference?
Legal Seafood.
Yes, opposite.
Does not take reservations,
but maintains a wait list
where customers who have
been on the wait list longer
are seated earlier.
Sometimes customers decide
to eat somewhere else,
so restaurant must remove
them from the wait list.
OK.
Assume that a customer
has a different name.
No two customers are
added to the wait list
at the exact same time.
So there's a kind of an
ordering at which people are
being added to this wait list.
Does that makes sense?
Design a database to help
Criminals Seafood maintain
its wait lists
supporting the following
operations, each
in constant time.
OK, so here, we've refactored
the running time up to the top.
And it's a-- oh, sorry.
I added the build here.
I guess that's
still constant time.
That's fine, OK.
AUDIENCE: I have time d--
JASON KU: Yeah.
State whether each running
time operation is worst case,
amortized, expected.
So, when you see that
statement, you're saying, OK,
I'm allowed to use a
hash table if I want to.
I just have to make
sure if I use one,
I label my operations expected
and amortized when they occur.
Which operations are expected?
Basically all of them.
Which operations are amortized?
The ones that changed what's
in the data structure, insert,
delete.
OK.
So we've got some operations,
building an empty thing.
Adding a name-- so this name is
x to the back of the wait list.
What do I know about x?
What do I know about the
names per our assumptions
in this class?
AUDIENCE: They're unique,
so they can be a key.
JASON KU: They're unique,
And they fit in a
constant number of words
by our assumption.
So I can compare
two of them in--
or I can hash one
in constant time.
That's kind of the assumption
we make on these inputs,
they're strings.
And I didn't assign you
a bound on their length,
so it's probably not something
you need to worry about.
OK remove a name.
So already I'm
feeling like, I need
to be able to find
things by their name.
OK.
And then seat the
next person in line.
Does that makes sense?
So what kinds of things do
I need to maintain here?
I have people.
They have names and they
have kind of places,
the time that they came in.
But am I given the times?
No.
I'm not given times anywhere.
It's not on the inputs
to my operations.
So it's not like I'm going
to be able to key on time.
That makes sense?
What's the important
part about the times?
The order.
AUDIENCE: And you're given that.
JASON KU: Yeah.
Basically whenever--
I'm basically
trying to maintain a
sequence on these guys.
There's a front one and a back
one and people in the middle.
And I want to make sure
that order stays the same,
or else people are going
to getting angry at me,
because ah, they came here
after me and I got a--
yeah.
You've been in that situation.
OK.
So, we're trying to maintain
some kind of sequence,
an extrinsic order
on these things.
But we're also needing to
be able to look up people
by their name because I want to
be able to change this thing.
Does this maybe sound familiar
to some other problem we had
on this term's problem sets?
Yeah, I think there
was a problem where--
AUDIENCE: The chat.
JASON KU: The chat.
You had to store a sequence.
But you also had this dictionary
that you had to look things up.
Now the nice thing
about that situation
is that the things that
you needed to look up on
was static.
And so what could I
use for my dictionary,
my sets data structure for that?
Anyone remember?
You could just use
a sorted array.
Because it's
static, these things
aren't updating all the time,
and so it was fine for me
to just use a static array.
Here-- and we gave
you lookup times that
were worst case logarithmic.
Here, I'm asking
for constant time.
Sorted array is not
going to cut it,
set AVL's not going to cut
it, so what am I going to use?
AUDIENCE: Dynamic--
JASON KU: A dynamic
array or a hash table.
Now dynamic array might not be
great because I don't actually
have a numeric bound on
how big these keys are,
I just know that
they fit in words.
So I can't actually make
a direct access array
because those words--
while they fit in a
constant number of words,
I don't know if the integer
representation of those
are polynomial-bounded.
Does that make sense?
So I do want to use
hashing in this case.
And so what do I
want to maintain?
I want to maintain a sequence
data structure on customers.
Customers.
Is there a U in there somewhere?
No.
This is right, right?
OK.
And a set mapping.
So this is usually how I do it.
Like I want to say a
set keyed on something.
If it's just a set,
then I just have it key.
I can look up whether that
thing is there or not.
But when I'm actually having
it mapped to something else,
I'll say, mapping a key, space,
to something else, usually
the item that I'm
storing or maybe
some property of the
items that I'm storing.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So mapping, what do I map here?
Names.
To-- oh.
To what?
Do I want to map?
AUDIENCE: To time--
JASON KU: The time.
The time that they entered.
Do I want to do that?
AUDIENCE: Well, you can't
exactly do it with the time
that they entered, but the
sequence on the customers
will show what's next in line.
JASON KU: Yeah.
I want to store it to where
it is in this sequence.
So I'll just store the index
where it is in the sequence
and I can just look it up.
That's sounds-- yeah?
Is that what--
AUDIENCE: I thought
the indices change.
JASON KU: Yeah.
Indices change every time
I add or remove things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Ah, yeah.
Store a pointer.
Pointer to place in sequence.
Now, that's a
little weird to say,
because I haven't told you how
I represented this sequence.
But conceptually I can
say I'm drawing a pointer
to someplace in
this that represents
where it is, I'll deal with
the details of that later.
But generally I call this
a linked data structure,
because I'm linking
between two data structures
so that I can do a query in one,
say, and find out where it is
and the other.
Or do a query in the
other, that kind of thing.
So, everyone kind of understand
why I chose these things?
How I approached this problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure how
a pointer fixes the problem
of just storing an index.
The place that a person
is at in the sequence
is going to change over time.
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --assuming that a
pointer updates, would that
change?
JASON KU: So-- OK.
So let's say if every time--
so let's say I'm storing--
let's say I'm storing this
sequence in a linked list,
let's just say,
because I know that I'm
going to have to be
inserting and deleting things
from the middle of this thing.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So I'm going to go
ahead and say that this
is going to be a linked list.
Now I have this linked list.
So if I said, all right, the
set data structure in my set
stores--
or stores where it is
in the linked list,
let's say it's stored
at k, all right?
Cool.
Now if I seat this guy,
I stick him at his table,
every index has changed.
So for me to update the
indices stored in this set data
structure, I have to change
every single one of them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JASON KU: Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no, this
makes way more sense.
JASON KU: Yeah.
So really what I want, not
to store a number here,
but an actual pointer
to the node that's
containing this thing,
because the node
isn't changing unless that
thing left my data structure.
The node, the address of this
thing in memory, the node
is just a little
container that contains
an item and the next
pointer, and actually we're
going to need a
previous pointer here.
We're going to need
a doubly-linked list.
Because what we're going to
do when we remove something,
we need to stitch
it back together
in constant time,
which means we need
to know what's the one in front
of us and the one behind us.
Yeah?
No?
All right.
So linked list here.
We already said maybe
using a hash table here.
And so, OK, great.
This is basically
enough for me to say,
this is my data structure,
these are the invariants.
What are the invariants?
It's storing all the customers.
That's an invariant.
I mean, it's not a very
strong invariant, but it's--
yeah, I mean, I should say that.
I'm storing all the
customers because I'm
going to have to make sure
that I'm maintaining that when
I do a query.
And then here, set
mapping names to pointers.
The place in this thing.
And as I remove things,
I need to make sure
that invariant stays the same.
It's still mapping all
the names of customers
that I have in my
thing to their nodes.
So when something
leaves, I better
need to make sure that both
of these things are updated.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So how do I maintain
these operations?
We've got a build--
build just sets up
empty of these things.
It's easier to say that.
I build an empty linked
list, doubly-linked lists
on the customers,
and I build a set--
a hash table mapping nothing
to nothing right now.
OK.
So that's build.
I'm going to be precise
here and actually
write down the thing
because I told you not
to ignore a
operation, or else we
can't give you points for it.
The next one-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: By emptying-- by
building an empty linked list--
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: --it just has
like the head and the tail,
it's actually none,
but, like, it exists?
JASON KU: Yeah, right.
It's a thing in
memory that we store.
It has a pointer to
a head and a tail.
Those are none right now.
But we will add things to it.
OK.
So the second one, add name.
What do we have to say?
We have to update this
data structure so it
maintains it's a variance.
I have to-- usually I
start with one of them.
I get to a point
where, oh, I really
should have updated
the other one first.
So sometimes it's hit or miss.
What do I want to do here?
Well, I have no idea where
in this sequence this is.
So I kind of have
to go here first.
Oh, sorry.
Adding a guy, I
could do either way.
I know-- where is
he going to go?
End of the list.
So I just stick it there.
So add x to end of sequence.
So I come to a
trick that I like.
Sequence, set.
OK.
In this instance I only have
one sequence and one set.
And so calling them sequence
and set, probably fine.
I'm not going to
confuse the greater,
I'm not going to confuse myself.
But when I have more
than one of these things,
or even for brevity on an exam
where I'm time-constrained,
give these things a name.
Say this is a sequence
C and M. I don't know.
I see customer here, I
see a map here, so maybe.
I don't know.
But just give them
a letter, then we
can follow you much more
clearly and you can refer
to these things more precisely.
So end of C.
Then what do we have to do?
I fix this guy, this guy's good.
Now I have to fix this guy.
So I add x to the set and
I map it back to that node
that I just came from.
I could store it in
a temporary variable.
Add x to M pointing
to n node v to v. OK.
Cool?
So, I added my x to the end of
C into a node v. I'm kind of--
I labeled it so I can
reference it later.
And in code, I would probably
remember what that node was.
Add x to M pointing
to that node,
and now I've maintained
my invariant.
Great.
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: Add key x.
Or add x to M having the
key of x point to that node.
Does that make sense?
There's a subtlety there.
3 3, we have remove--
I don't remember
the name, whatever.
OK.
So here, we have to do--
order matters.
I don't know where it
is in the sequence,
but I'm going to look
it up in the set,
and I'm going to
remove it from the set,
and I'm going to look
at whatever it points to
and remove it from the sequence.
I'm running out of
time a little bit here,
so I'm not going to
write all that down.
You guys understand
what that means.
Here, we're using
the fact that it's
a doubly-linked list so that
we can relink things together.
You don't have to tell
me the three points--
the previous pointer of my
next thing to the next-- the--
right?
You don't have to
tell me how to relink
those pointers because we did
that already in problem set 1
or whatever.
AUDIENCE: Just in general, as
you're in a situation for where
you're using not a
doubly-linked list--
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: where
just a linked list
would be better than
a doubly linked list
because it seems like it
always solves problems.
JASON KU: Yeah.
Doubly-linked lists is
almost always strictly better
than a singly-linked
in theory problems.
So yeah, use it.
OK.
And then seat, last one.
That's just take the
front of the sequence,
remove it, change
the head around,
but I get that you
can delete first.
You're reducing to the
interface that we had.
You're deleting first
on the sequence.
But now, we have a situation.
I deleted the first guy.
How do I know who
the first guy is?
Well, I'm storing
its name in there.
I'm storing the names
of these customers.
So I know who is at the
front, I look in this set data
structure, and I
remove that entry.
Does that makes sense?
Because now, I no longer need
to maintain where he goes.
Now in actuality,
I could just not
update this set data structure.
But if I do that, then,
well, my running times
are still linear time.
I'm not giving you
a bound on space.
I'm still constant time, sorry.
So you don't actually
have to do that removal,
but if that customer
comes back and wants
to get on the wait list again,
there are things to consider.
OK.
So that's that question.
Next question, last
10 minutes or so.
Raniy Research.
This is a problem that
people had nightmares about.
OK, so basically we've
got a Meather Wan.
He's a weatherman.
A scientist who studies
global rainfall.
And he's got a bunch
of sensors everywhere.
And each one can post to
the cloud or something
a measurement that's
of the form a triple
of integers r, l,
and t where r is
a positive amount of
rainfall, an integer;
a latitude, an integer
again; and at a time.
We got three things
to deal with here.
Yuck.
But they're all integers.
And don't be like,
oh, well Jason,
latitudes are pretty small.
So I can assume these
integers are small
and these things
take constant time.
I'm not specifying to
you a resolution at which
I'm measuring these integers.
And I haven't given you a bound
between what that resolution is
compared to the number of
measurements that I have,
so I don't play those games.
OK.
The peak rainfall
at a given latitude
since a particular time
is the maximum rainfall
at any measurement at that
latitude measured at a time
greater than or
equal to that time.
Does that make sense?
Or 0 if there aren't
measurements at that latitude.
OK.
To score after the time-- or
before the time or whatever.
Describe a database that we
can build it in constant time.
Is an empty one--
I added this one
because we weren't
good about that last spring.
Record data.
We give you a triplet.
And then-- so record data,
for it to be correct,
I just have to maintain
that information.
For these kind of
updates, I don't--
it's really hard for me to argue
that this thing is correct.
Because I just--
I throw it at the
database, the database
doesn't have to give
anything back to me.
So the important thing
here about correctness
is that peak rainfall gives
it to me and it gives it to me
in the time bound
that I'm looking for.
And peak rainfall is
returning the peak rainfall
at a particular
latitude since t.
So we have three things.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Given
that you never have
to return a single measurement,
is that [INAUDIBLE]
have a record of it?
JASON KU: There's the
potential that you
don't need to store
all of the information
because all we're
doing is giving you
back R's, essentially.
It's possible that you don't
need to store the latitudes
or times at all.
You don't even need
to store the triplets.
Now in reality, I'm querying
on the latitudes and the times.
So I should store
them somewhere,
but I might be able
to compress them.
In particular, many things could
be stored at the same latitude.
That's kind of the whole
point of the query.
And so we want--
I mean, we may only need to
store that latitude once.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
I'm going to wait
for questions until
after because I want to get
to a solution to this problem.
All right.
So what do we need to do?
We need to be able
to add things.
And I want to return.
So return, I'm going to
have to query something,
and then I'm going
to return something.
So return peak rainfall at
latitude l since time t.
What do I care about
in a particular query?
I only care about all the
things at l, at a latitude l.
So really, this isn't
such an interesting thing,
but I want to be able to have
maybe many data structures, one
associated with each L.
Does that make sense?
And how can I find
one in each L quickly?
Put it in a dictionary.
What's my time bound?
Worst case log n.
So what data structure do I use
for that set data structure?
A set AVL.
So you're going to
first have a set AVL--
say, L-- mapping latitudes to--
well, now we have
more data structures.
I want to store a lot
of the things that
have the same latitudes
in another data structure.
The ones probably
storing the times
in the rainfalls of
all those measurements.
Yeah?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A hash table.
JASON KU: A hash table.
OK, so what kinds
of query am I going
to want to do on the things
at the same latitude?
AUDIENCE: You're going
to want to get the times.
JASON KU: I'm going to
want to get the times,
but more than that, I'm doing
kind of an ordered query.
I need the things less
than a certain time.
Greater, sorry.
AUDIENCE: So it's really--
JASON KU: Just a second.
AUDIENCE: Could you do
like an AVL for the time
and an AVL for the rain?
JASON KU: OK.
Do I care about an
AVL for the rain?
I mean, looking up
on the rainfall.
AUDIENCE: No.
JASON KU: No.
So I'm going to go ahead
and store these things
in a time-sorted AVL to
mapping latitude l to--
I'm going to call this
data structure a time data
structure.
I'm going to say it's t of l.
That kind of looks
like a recurrence,
so it's a little
irking me right now,
but I don't have
anything better.
All right.
So now each one of these
time data structures
is a set AVL mapping time
to the rainfall measurement.
All right.
So that's going to--
if my query was, return
the peak rainfall--
sorry.
Return the rainfall of the thing
with latitude l and time t,
we'd be done, kind of.
You'd know how to
support that query.
To insert things,
I insert things
into both data structures,
and I just look it up.
The one complication
here is that I'm not
asking for what is the
rainfall at a particular time.
I want to know what the maximum
rainfall is up to this time.
OK.
So max heap's good if I
want to know the global max.
But here, I want to know the
max bounded by a certain range.
So we're going to--
you can ask me
questions after this,
we're running out of
time a little bit.
So anyone have an idea for how--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you just
augment the AVL with the max?
JASON KU: OK.
AUDIENCE: And you can just
look at the right child
and then just look at
the max at that point?
JASON KU: Ah, OK.
So what your
colleague is saying,
if we augment by the
max r in my subtree,
maybe we can use that to
figure out this query.
Because we're ordered
on t, right we
have this nice monotonic
property that everything that's
going to be in my query--
everything to the right
of a certain time--
if my time is above t
at a particular node,
in everything in
the right subtree
is also above that t because
of the order of my set's data
structure, because
I'm ordered on times.
So there's maybe the
possibility that if I
look to my right
subtree, I can not
do work all over
here by just looking
at the max in that subtree.
so That's an idea of, let's
say, augmented by subtree max r.
You probably want to
give this a name as well.
So like v max where v
is a node in my thing.
And I want to show how to
support this, how I can compute
that from its children.
So how do I actually
support this query,
I can think of it recursively.
I have a couple of cases.
If I'm at a v here, I want to
define a recursive function
that's called peak rainfall
of a given node lower bounded
by a t.
So if I'm here,
there's two cases.
Either my t, my time is bigger
or smaller-- is in my range
or out of my range.
If it's out of my
range, what do I do?
It's lower than my time bound.
I can just recursively call
this function on this node.
Because I know that
anything is going
to be down here
that I care about.
And that's just one
recursive call down the tree.
And so if I only limit myself
to one recursive call down
the tree, I'm always
going down each time.
This is going to take
logarithmic time.
So that's the first case,
that's the easy case.
This thing is not in range, I
return recursively the thing
to my right.
What's the other case?
I'm in my range.
Well now I could return,
recursively call both sides.
Because that's what this
peak is talking about.
What's my peak rainfall?
But if I do that, if I
call it here recursively
and I call it here recursively,
that could take linear time.
I might touch every
node in my tree.
So why did I do
this augmentation?
So I don't have to
do work on this node.
I just return the maximum
rainfall in this subtree,
and then recurse on this side.
So I did constant
work on this side,
I did one recursive
call down here
which you could go to the
bottom, but that's OK,
I can afford to go to
the bottom of the tree.
Does that makes sense?
And if I don't have either
subtree, then I'm done.
If at any time.
I don't have the node
that I'm supposed
to recurse on, I take the
max of this subtree, myself,
and whatever the recursive
return value is here.
And comparing three values,
returning their max.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So that's what we call
a one-sided range query.
So in the-- I think problem
session 4 that I didn't get to,
it shows you a way to do this
for a two-sided range query
where I need to know the maximum
of all things between two
things.
But it's really no more
difficult than this
to finding a recursive function
that uses an augmentation so
that you don't have to do
recursive call on both sides.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
That's going to be it for now,
and I can take questions after.
Thanks for coming.